and and uh time for the final talk of of
uh for this morning before the lunch
break so uh Mahajan uh we'll talk about
QPS and proofs for Curious
talk I'm going to be talking about qbs2
complexity and this is a kind of
overview talk of stuff that has happened
unlike with sat qbf proof complexity is
uh has a history of only 20 25 years so
this is less to cover but just give a
snapshot of where we are now and what
still needs to be left
uh so the So the plan of the top is that
I'll try most of the talk I will focus
on the proof complexity perspective
but a little bit uh at some point I will
also talk about from the qb8 solving
side what is it that can be said and
towards the end a little little bit from
computational complexity which is the
perspective from which I come in
actually
so maybe initially little bit of qbf
Basics just to make sure that we are all
talking about the same thing and
depending on the time at the end some
speculations
but so what are Quantified Boolean
formulas well we know propositional uh
satisfiability the question
propositional satisfiability is asking
whether for some propositional formula
there is an assignment to the variables
which satisfies all the constraints
satisfies the formula and this could be
restated as a Quantified formula by
simply sticking in a prefix which
explicitly says does there exist an X1
and X exists and X2 and so on so all the
variables are Quantified existently and
in qbf the generalization that we allow
is that Universal quantifiers are
allowed as well so each variable has its
own quantifier which could be either
existential or Universal and then we are
looking at a sentence of this form and
we want to know now whether the sentence
is true or false so now we wouldn't talk
about is it satisfiable or no because if
all the variables are Quantified then
it's either true or it's false and we
want to know which of these is true
so expressing constraints in this form
it's it's not going to allow us to say
more things than that than could have
been said with propositional
satisfiability but very often the X the
expression is more succinct it leads to
a smaller formula it may be more natural
more explainable to write down your
constraints in qba and uh so so there's
good reason to write certain constraints
in qba form rather than this
propositional satisfiability deciding
whether it's true or false is a much
harder question it's a piece based
complete
in in most of the qvf proof complexity
literature so far we consider QBs which
are in this standard form so I'll stick
to this but one could also go beyond
this so we will assume that the formulas
are totally Quantified there are no free
variables and we also assume that it's
in Linux form all the quantifiers appear
right in the beginning
not interleaved in inside the formula
and we assume that the inner
propositional formula is in conjunctive
normal form it's a bunch of Clauses and
this is just the simplest way of
extending going beyond what has been
done for CNF sat to the context of QPS
so the two player evaluation game is
something which is very uh useful to
keep in mind when thinking about QBs uh
especially when thinking about how one
would try to decide whether the qbf is
true or false so there's this two there
are these two players who step through
the quantifier prefix of the formula and
there is a universal player who owns the
universal variables there's the
existential player who owns the
existential variables and they have to
choose values for the variables in the
order of the prefix once all the
variables have been assigned then the
inner formula can actually be evaluated
to true or false if it turns out to be
true then the existential player has one
if it turns out to be false the
universal player has one on that
particular run but we are not just
interested in winning on a particular
run we would like to know whether uh a
player can always force a win on every
run no matter how the opponent plays and
uh it's always the case that one of the
two players has a winning strategy it's
if it's the existential player then
that's exactly a model or a scholar
function if it's a universal player then
it's a counter model or her brand
function and we want to determine which
which of these holds which of the
players actually has a winning strategy
so many of the proof systems that have
been designed actually have this thing
in mind about looking at strategies
using them to design the proofs using
them to reason about approved systems so
which is why I just wanted to make sure
that this terminology we are all
familiar with right in the beginning
okay so um I mean that's all I wanted to
say about the basic let's go to the
proof complexity uh perspective what is
it that we expect from a proof system so
we want proofs to be short of course we
want them to be efficiently verifiable
again of course and these are like even
more obvious requirements we want the
proof system to be sound it should not
be able to prove a statement which is
actually false we want the proof system
to be complete every true statement
which is indeed true should be provable
in in this system
for for propositional formulas there are
several proof systems which have been
studied with a much longer history than
qbf and as we have seen propositional
proof systems are handling essentially a
special case of QBs QBs where you have
only existential quantifiers right in
the beginning so now
what we would like to think of uh for
qvf group systems is how are we going to
take existing propositional systems and
augment to them it's not necessary that
we think this way we may like think from
scratch starting directly with qba but
many of the existing proof systems
actually came into existence by the this
kind of thought process start with a
propositional group system and then add
more rules to it so that it can handle
the full generality of two years and
because in the propositional case we are
trying to prove cnx false
so I mean maybe as a historical accident
in QBs also the initial proof systems
focus more on looking at uh trying to
prove a qbf is false there is of course
a duality true or false are equally hard
computationally but we are going to look
at group systems which can prove false
cubes
so how are we going to ensure that the
resulting proof systems in whatever way
we augment them how are we going to
ensure that their sound typically this
is done by showing that the augmented
rule is thrown in whenever there is a
proof uh refutation a proof that a
certain PBF is false by examining that
proof we should be able to extract a
representation of a counter model or a
brand function then that would tell us
that indeed the formula was false so so
many soundness proofs for proof systems
are actually followed this way of
extracting a counter model from a
refutation
how would we ensure completeness well
there are there are three four different
paradigms which we have seen in the
literature so far uh expansion Universal
reduction literal merging maybe it's
easier to do this through some figures
so here's a here's a small example and
on this example I will just illustrate
these four paradigms in their most basic
forms so this this formula is saying
that there exists an X so that no matter
how you choose U there is a response Y
which so that the assignment x u y
satisfies all these Clauses this qbf is
false and there is a winning strategy
for the universal player for choosing
you and here is how I would prove this
in some kind of a group system the first
the most obvious Brook system is
expansion where you just think of the
universal quantifier as a conjunction
and that's not a universal quantifier
literally means so you look at the
formula starting from U and say that
well this is the conjunction of the
inner formula at U equals 0 and at U
equals one so that's going to give rise
to Clauses like this why corresponding
to U equals 0 the Y corresponding to U
equals one the other two Clauses also
have their versions with appropriate
markers saying which copy they came from
and then when it's a purely
propositional formula the universal
quantifier has been eliminated and we
can do ordinary resolution or whatever
you wish so this is this is expansion
and resolution and this this finally
allows us to derive the MP Clause so
therefore the initial formula was formed
so this was in fact one of the earliest
uh kind of qvf group systems here's a
different style of a qvf group system
where you start off doing reduction
resolution as you would in the
propositional world start off with the
original Clauses and when you reach a
clause which looks like this xor U well
in this U is a universal variable and it
is trailing as far as the quantifier
prefix is concerned this is the right
most variable and
one can show that it is sound number
these circumstances to Simply
instantiate that Universal variable you
can instantiate it to true or to false
and add that new Clause to your system
and this would preserve a winning
strategy of the existential layer so
it's it's okay to derive this Clause
from here as well so this is the
universal reduction Rule and using this
you can derive an empty flow s so this
is the reduction
and you can use this in combination with
other things this is the expansion
Paradigm there's a more complex Paradigm
which has these kind of strange markers
which says that I can resolve these two
Clauses on X even though U is appearing
in different polarities and
this does not mean that I'm going to put
U and U Bar into my uh resolvent Clause
that would mean that the resolvent
Clause is true it just means that at
this point the universal player has a
way of assigning values to you if you
are going to win by falsifying this
Clause that method can be carried over
provided x is 0 if if U has a method of
winning by falsifying this Clause then
that method can be carried over provided
X is one and so so this is a kind of a
placeholder for the strategy so this is
the long distance resolution where you
are resolving two Clauses even though
they differ in polarity on more than one
variable and there are systems based on
this rule also
this is a Fourth Kind of Paradigm which
is explicitly separating out the
existential part and the universal part
on the existential part of each Clause
you perform ordinary resolution and then
on the universal part you start building
up what could be a potential counter
model
at this Clause the counter model must
set u equals zero if it wants to falsify
this Clause at this point it must be one
and then you start merging together the
partial counter models so the exact data
is the syntax of the rules is not
important conceptually what these four
systems are doing in some sense they are
different so this is what I refer to
here when I said that there are these
four different uh paradigms and with
these there are various group systems
which have been defined in the
literature this is the vanilla expansion
and Universal expansion and resolution
system
um
this is ordinary resolution with the
universal reduction rule this is also
resolution to the universal reduction
rule these two are systems which add
that literal merging on top of reduction
this is a system which adds literal
merging on top of expansion this is a
system which tries to build up counter
models so there are all these systems
which are starting with ordinary
resolution for the propositional
formulas and augmenting resolution in
some way in in different ways so
at this point you can see that it
doesn't really make sense to talk about
qbf resolution there is no one system
which is qbf resolution these are all
systems which went up when they are
given propositional formulas they
degenerate to resolution
so the the
as a as an accident of History this has
been called Q resolution because this
was the first reduction based system but
I would say that all of these are in
some sense qbf resolution
none of them are overly powerful in some
sense so so one could also Define a
reduction system like this which takes
the propositional system of e fragate
not resolution and adds a universal
reduction rule to it and that system
sits on top of all of these so this is
again another sanity check that these
proof systems are not doing something
which is completely weird and the
extended fragile system with universal
reduction
best fit inside another formal system
curat which is a format for writing
proofs for QBs generalizing Beyond The
derate Format which has been used for
propositional formulas
so this is the simulation order amongst
these resolution based systems all these
simulations These are systems are going
up in more increasingly more power the
most of the separation will all these
separations here are actually
exponential there are formulas which are
which have short proofs here and have
require exponential length here
almost all though not all almost all of
the missing connections are actually non
simulations we have so we have a whole
lot of lower bonds to show that uh
formulas are hard for various systems
here
so just a brief comment on this
augmenting uh propositional proof
systems the expansion Paradigm would
work for any propositional groups
because expansion just says that you
interpret a universal quantifier as
conjunction which indeed is what it is
so you can take any propositional proof
system and
do expansion and you would get a qbf2
system Universal reduction adding this
rule works for almost all line based uh
group systems but these Notions of
literal merging or building up counter
models so far they have been done for
resolution it's not even clear that
these paradigms can be applied to other
other systems so in fact so so these
were the four uh kind of ways of
extending propositional proof systems
that I described and I don't know
whether there are other paradigms as
well which we have not yet discovered we
have not yet thought of maybe there are
so this would be something uh to think
about
foreign
okay so in the simulation order for
these proof systems I'm not going to
give the like I said the technical or
syntactic details uh description of this
group systems because the ideas Behind
These so I I mentioned that these
separations that that we have
exponential separations which of course
means that we have lower bonds we have
we know formulas which are provably hard
for some of these systems so how do we
prove these lower bounds I just want to
briefly go over what are the techniques
we have for proving lower bounds for qvf
systems
um one thing one could do is to Simply
transfer propositional hardness
take any reasonable qbf proof system it
doesn't necessarily have to be a qbf2
system which was defined by starting
with a propositional system and
augmenting it it could have I mean you
could have come up with a qvf2 system
from anywhere but inside it there you
would expect that there is an easily
described embedded propositional system
what what about your given system pay do
if it were given purely propositional
formulas the the rules the way it would
apply them that would describe a
propositional proof system Q
and inside any reasonable uh qbf group
system P where the underlying
propositional version is Q if I start
with an unsatisfiable Formula F
and I look at refutations of there
exists F in p i look at proving
unsatisfiability of F and Q obviously
this is not going to be uh any uh easier
in the qvf group system it cannot do
anything more than what could have been
done in the underlying based system so
this means that if I have propositional
lower bounds which of course we do they
all directly transfer to the QBs group
systems so it's not just a question of
saying do we have lower bounds for these
two systems of course we do because
sitting inside all of them are
propositional systems for which we have
lower bonds what we really would be
looking for here is do we have lower
bounds for formulas where the hardness
is coming because of the fact that there
were there was quantifier alternation
so it's not purely propositional
hardness that we are interested in and
we are not interested in only because
there is another body of work which is
already addressing that not because it's
not interesting but in the context of
qbf complexity we want to see where the
alternations are adding to hardens so we
would like to understand what is this
genuine qbf hardness and what kind of
formulas are hard in that sense not just
because of professionalism
so for instance feasible interpolation
this is a technique which has been used
to give many lower bounds for
propositional proof systems and indeed
it can also be used to be lower bonds
for many qvf group systems as well so
the Q resolution q u resolution or the
long distance world so for for many of
them feasible interpolation as a lower
round technique works and it shows that
formulas which are not propositional
formulas which actually have Universal
quantifiers in them it shows that those
formulas are hard to refute in these
systems so one would think that okay
this is not propositional hardness but
actually if you dig through a little bit
more closely you find that this in some
sense this is still not genuine qbf
hardness because what the feasible
interpolation technique does is it
identifies chunks of any allergic to
proof which must be very large and those
chunks are actually doing purely
propositional reasoning
even though the the formula cannot be
stated using uh without a universal
quantifiers the lower bonds which this
throws up is the lower bounds are
focusing entirely on Parts which have
propositional needs the same thing holds
for some lower bonds which are proved
using proven delayer games so
probability layer games have been used
to prove lower bounds entry like Q
resolution one of the weakest systems in
that diagram that I had earlier but
again those lower bonds even though they
are for formulas with quantifiers they
are actually focusing on Parts which
have proposition in business yeah so
here's a very vague question I'm
thinking about this reasonable qbf
process now I mean is it clear and
purely that you know maybe I'm given a
tricky CNF formula but if I'm
equipped with qbf reasoning maybe I
could do something amazing GPS by the
reason to actually break the hardness of
this piece level is there because of
that yeah so so if your formula is
purely propositional but but it's in
some sense very hard how could you use
qbf reasoning maybe if you think of
something like an extended resolution
system where you are allowed to
introduce new Universal variables and
then you do qvf reasoning well I don't
know what's going to happen
so that's that that's the kind of thing
that I have in mind it's sort of related
to what you said earlier that there
might be other paradigms that so you
don't think of propositional don't you
don't have to think only a propositional
plus something more you may have
designed a new vehicle system which
started from somewhere else and then
it's a restriction I'm not very sure
that this will always be the rules
okay so uh so this slide is about
propositional hardness then it can be
transferred and does it really say
something meaningful and I I claim that
at least this kind of hardness is not uh
meaningful unless the system is doing
something really non-trivial
so in fact this leads us to the question
what do they mean by genuine qba finals
it's such a weird phrase no and uh so if
we want to understand this well this is
a at a very intuitive level this is what
I mean by it so the hardness in Refuge
uh in refuting some formula in a
particular system should not stem merely
from uh underlying propositional
hardness and what do we mean by
underlying propositional hardness you
need to formalize it in some way in
expansion systems the formalization is
completely straightforward you're you're
expanding out the universal uh
quantifier and so the cost of the
quantification is the size of the
expanded formula the part of the
expansion that you actually need to use
but in reduction systems one very neat
way of formalizing this has been the use
of an NP Oracle and essentially what it
amounts to is you discount any reduction
steps
any steps that employee reasoning which
is checkable by reduction to set so
those those steps may be involving
existing variables Universal variables
that that is not important part the
point is that the that entire reasoning
you could check simply by a reduction to
set and in a reaction based system what
the okay these two reductions are
different reductions
so in a direction system effectively
this amounts to saying you count only
the reduction steps everything else is
propositionally checkable because it's a
propositional proof system plus
reduction so you discount the
propositional part and discount how many
reduction steps are used
in systems which use merging you would
want to Discount deduction steps where
these partial counter models or partial
strategies don't increase in complexity
then you know that part has remained
untouched even even if it was not
trivial to begin with well whatever
non-triviality it had if it did not
change over a sequence of derivations
then that derivation
so these are the parts which we want to
Discount and then we want to say is is
the formula still hard to refute so not
counting these steps do you still
require a very lengthy reputation and we
do have genuine lower bounds in this
sense as well one could also ask why do
we stop at an NP Oracle like like I've
said ubf is p space complete so there's
a there's a whole hierarchy between NP
and P space so you could Peg your
definition of what is genuine hardness
anywhere in that hierarchy and this has
also been done there are some very nice
results which show for various types of
oracles at levels of the polynomial
hierarchy you have formulas which are
hard to recruit despite their access to
that
so so this whole notion of formalizing
genuine qba Partners is about
understanding the source of hardness
where is it coming from due to what kind
of alternations and structure within the
formula and I think there is more that
can be done here but it's really a nice
conceptual question
the other way of transferring lower
bounds is to try of obtaining lower
bonds for qvf systems is to transfer
computational hardness
so if you have some functions which are
computationally hard if you have some
languages that are computationally hard
can you use this to design formulas
which would be hard for a specific group
systems and in many qbf systems in fact
such computational hardness can be
transferred and the key idea is this
notion of efficient strategy extraction
every proof that a qbf is false contains
either implicitly or explicitly it
contains information about a counter
model I mean it's it's after all it's
proving that the formula is false so
it's proving that there does exist a
counter model so that information is
encoded in the proof now how difficult
or easy is it to extract that
information to actually extract a
description of the uh Universal Players
winning strategy in almost all the proof
systems that we know the actual
extraction Works quite efficiently so
now the general template for these kind
of lower bounds is like this you start
with a proof system and you identify the
correct circuit model corresponding to
this group system so your circuit model
may be polynomial size circuits may be
polynomial size constant depth circuits
maybe decision lists decision trees
branching programs of a certain kind
whatever for every proof system
try to figure out what is the correct
circuit model
and what I mean by correct is that
whenever we have a refutation in this
group system of a certain size we should
be able to extract from this reputation
a description of the counter model
in that model in the model M so the
circuit model computes the winning
strategy of the universal player and the
description of the circuit in M should
be polynomial in the size of the
reputation
now if we're gonna find this then the
next thing we would want to do is to
find some Boolean function which is
which has polynomial size circuits but
which is hard in this circuit model so
the circuit models will be typically
much more restrictive than polynomial
size circuits and you want to find a
function which is hard for that model
and now it's completely straightforward
we can construct false qbfs in fact they
are Sigma 3 formulas which uh in which
there is just one winning strategy for
the universal player that winning
strategy is forced to compute f if the
winning strategy com uh chooses for a
universal value a variable a value other
than
the function f computed in the
existential variables then the
existential layer can win so the formula
somehow has to assert that
uh f is computed on the existential
variables this can be done it's not very
complicated and once you do this now you
have uh okay I go to the next thing yeah
now we immediately have lower mounts
because
putting together these two ideas any
short refutation for this corresponding
Sigma 3 formula would give rise to a
small circuit Computing F but we know
that there are no small circuits
Computing F of that type
in particular if you look at Freddy
style proof systems uh reggae with the
universal reduction rule thrown in and
maybe the project style systems are
looking at a restricted kind of circuit
uh then this very nice work done by
olafanya and they showed that there are
only two sources of hardness in in such
systems either there is a propositional
related formula which is hard or there
is a lower Bound for the circuit Class C
the propositional formula unders lower
boundary are also very nicely stated
here from any proof in such a qvf group
system we can efficiently extract a set
of witnessing circuits so these
witnessing circuits are actually
Computing the
uh winning strategy of the universal
player the her brand function and a
propositional proof that those circuits
actually constitute a winning strategy
so from any any reputation I can extract
a description of the counter model and a
validation that this is indeed a
countable so if either of these two
tasks is hard then there is no shortcut
and in fact with this template now it
turns out that we can even give lower
bounds for uh frege plus reduction
systems where every line must be an AC 0
mod 2. uh it's okay now this is a
famously open problem in the
propositional case but in the qbf world
yes we do have such lower amounts
and it's it's simply because we do have
circuit lower bounds here so we know
that there are not going to be any
witnessing circuits
so this is a different way of uh
transferring uh computational hardness
a third way of transferring
computational level not a third way but
a third viewpoint on this so in the in
the propositional word the seismic
relation has played a very prominent
role in proving uh lower mountains and
uh so so it was very natural to explore
whether there is a similar such relation
in the qbf world and would that lead to
lower bounds well very very quite some
years ago we realized that this does not
work for Q resolution
fails completely and that seemed to be a
bit of a stumbling Rock but a little uh
later a few years later we realized that
in fact there is a modified adaptation
of that relation which does work for Q U
resolution this is resolution plus
reduction so modified version of the
size bit relation which actually takes
into account the alternation depths also
uh holds here it does give lower bounds
for bounded alternation formulas not for
arbitrary uh full queue yes and the main
idea behind this proof again turned out
to be a circuit characterization of this
tool system
so even though it looks like it's a
different approach via the size with
bound it's finally via circuit
characterization and transferring
circuit transferring a circuit lower
bound so this this method also it it
fits the template of transferring a
computational hardness if the winning
strategies are hard to compute then
related formulas will be hard to prove
faults in the systems
is there a third source of hardness so
there's propositional hardness there's
computational hardness it looks like
there may be a third source of Hardware
semantic hardness so there are various
systems uh between which are not as
strong as the frigate plus reduction
systems for which it can be shown that
certain formulas are hard these are
formulas where there is no underlying
propositional hardness and where the
winning strategies are completely
trivial to conclude
so it's not computational hardness of
the winning strategy and the way these
lower bounds have been proved there's a
series of uh papers which uh so so one
of them looks at the cost of a formula
this is a semantic measure of the
formula I'm not going to Define it I'm
just uh I just want to put out these
terms here to say that there are these
measures that can be defined and there
is a relation between the size of a
proof the cost of the formula and the
capacity of approved system
and this is used to be able lower bounds
for many reduction based systems there's
a different semantic measure called a
strategy size or the strategy weight of
a qbf which if it is large then one can
show lower bounds and expansion based
systems there's yet another measure
called the gauge of a formula if that is
large for a typically a sigma 3 kind of
formula then it would be hard in yet
another kind of
so these are measures of the formula
and what this approach is saying is that
if these measures are large then these
formulas will be hard to refute in a
corresponding proof system so since
these are measures of the formula itself
and they are not computational measures
these measures could be large even if
the form even if the winning strategies
are trivial to compute so it looks like
it's a different source of hardness it's
not computational hardness
so this is this is the question is it
really a third source and at least in
one case it looks like actually it is
not a different kind of hardness it's
again the same thing so there are these
so-called quality formulas uh where all
the semantic measures are very high cost
is high weight is high gauge is high so
they are high in therefore these
formulas are hard in multiple Roof
Systems winning strategies are
completely trivial you just each each
Universal variable U copies the value of
an earlier existential no no computation
is required
so one more thing that there is no
question of computational hardness to be
transferred because there is no
computation required but it turns out
that there is a computational model
which is multi-output decision list
where these strategies are hard to
compute and they are hard to compute
because this computational model expects
the entire block of universal values to
be given at one shot
so
when we say something is computationally
hard computationally easy it's it's not
automatic that we understand exactly
what is hard and easy it depends so much
on the model and
some work is required to find the right
model so this was a bit of a surprise at
this point that uh what seemed to be a
hardness stemming from a purely semantic
measure actually can be interpreted as a
computational hardness so maybe there is
more such there are more such
connections to Circuit models and proof
systems yet to be discovered and it
would be nice to clean up this picture
so the talk was about this proof
complexity perspective some of the
questions uh well the first one is
designing different proof systems
starting from the game semantics of qbf
so not starting from propositional proof
systems and building up but directly
thinking in qbf terms
of course there is polynomial calculus
plus reductions but static proof systems
I do not know what is the analog this is
in my opinion I really uh
blaring uh a area where we need to do
more work identifying more candidate
hard formula so there are very few
formulas and we're just playing around
with them and tweaking things here and
there
we should be able to understand hardness
better and for that we need more
candidate formulas so uh how how
everyone come up with candidate uh hard
formulas one is that we should be
exploiting the succinctness of qba over
over the propositional case
now there is are there mathematical
principles that are more naturally so so
in the propositional world these are the
uh Usual Suspects which in the whole
principle site in chess board they keep
cropping up what are analogous things
which should come up in the case of uh
Cubans so Stefan already mentioned some
mathematical uh theorems which are more
naturally imported as qbf and uh can we
try and uh formulate candidate hard
formula families based on these that
would be something about based on
computation of course this is something
that has been done and more can be done
here
uh another question which could be
looked at a little bit more is
formalizing the random formula model it
some work has already been done here but
I think there is a lot more to be done
understanding whether most formulas are
hard and what in from what distribution
they are so there's some stuff to be
done here
this I have already mentioned
characterizing proof systems via circuit
classes understanding the sources of
hardness uh so far I've mentioned three
sources and I'm already wondering
whether the third source is actually a
manifestation of the second but maybe
there is even a fourth source and fifth
source that we don't know about
okay so this is about the proof
complexity part let me move to the
third part from the yeah okay that's the
question I'm just curious I mean one
source of improved complexity
propositional proof complexity of one
source of hardness which would be like
yeah pigeon principle handshaking gamma
those kind of things but they're also
like you can take NP complete problems
people have been studying Clique and
coloring vertex cover right do you have
like your questions based on computation
that you know here you have piece based
completeness yeah are there any results
for like a nice encoding of a piece
based country problem and this is hard
for proof system such and such not that
I know of
um do you know any better Ola no no okay
good good yeah yeah I I don't know so
this has not been done the the
computation based hard formulas that we
know are the ones which are using
circuit computation hardness but they're
not using uniform hardness
okay so next segment with uh Cube we are
solving this I'll spend over five six
minutes on this
um
so we have heard a lot about cdcl uh so
far it's a non-deterministic template
for an algorithm which can decide
satisfiability and uh it's a template on
in when you actually instantiate it you
will plug in various heuristics and we
know that cdcl is equal to
resolution there are for every
resolution reputation there are choices
that could be made for the
non-deterministic uh non-inherent
non-rativism so that the cdcl run will
be of the same length with the
polynomial blur is there an analog of
this in the qvf world that's one
question that is very natural to ask for
so there are qbf solvers being built
they are again based on cdcl and is
there an analog saying that ubf
resolution is equal to CD cell well this
begs two questions firstly when we say
qbf resolution which one do we need
figure that I showed there were multiple
systems which were resolution and an
augmentation to qbf so it's not even
clear which is the correct group system
but even more it's not even clear what
is the correct Quantified cdcl algorithm
so you have the cdcl algorithm which
works for uh works for the propositional
propositional formula you want to lift
it to qbf again there are potentially
many ways in which this can be done so
which one of them is truly qcdcl maybe
maybe we don't have to say that this one
is the correct one maybe all of them are
fine but then do we have equivalences
for each one of them to some kind of
resolution based system I think it's
it's natural to expect that there should
be some such equivalence and the
question is to explore what these
equivalences are so having said this
maybe I should have a brief uh slide
describing what goes on in qbf solving I
know very little about QBs solving I
know that it is done and I know that
there is a qvf competition
um when I'm solvers based on expansion
and that that would be a natural thing
to do which is uh because like I said
the semantics of an expansion based
system is the most obvious one it's also
natural to expect that an expansion
based solver would somehow be limited
it would have to expand the formula and
that itself would incur a high cost so
some theoretical Studies have been done
there are the the expansion based proof
systems explain the runs of these
solvers but I think most of the qbf
solvers that are actually appearing at
the qvf competition are based on cdcl
and there there are many more questions
to be asked apart from the questions
which are asked in the case of the
propositional world there are more
questions which arise because we are
dealing with the qdf in particular the
reduction policy seems to almost all the
existing solvers I think use reduction
but there are things which could change
so maybe it doesn't make sense for me to
try and describe these terms now just to
say that there are more parameters and
of course that means that there is more
more complexity there are heuristics
which have been used in many of these uh
solvers in particular dependency schemes
I think are used in almost all of them
in some form or the other and what these
dependency schemes do is to say that
the cube in the QB of the variables are
listed out in the quantifier prefix and
we think of the truth or falseness of
the qbf based on a two-player game so
each player chooses the value of his or
variable knowing the values of all the
preceding variables
but maybe to actually win the game when
I am choosing the value of this variable
I don't even need to know all those
preceding values so does my does my
billing strategy actually depend on the
preceding values so one could talk about
a really required dependence or a
dependence which is there just because
by accident they were before uh this in
the prefix so dependency schemes try to
eliminate dependencies which are
spurious which are there because of a
linear order of the variable but which
Play No role as far as actually
constructing a winning strategy is
concerned so somehow you can just
analyze the structure of the formula the
Clause is variable incidence the
connections between various variables
through resolution paths and figure out
that certain dependencies
which come from the linear prefix are
immaterial and discarded so then you can
use that along the way in the cdcl
solver there's also dependency learning
which stays the diametrically opposite
view instead of starting with all the
dependencies from the prefix and then
throwing out some you start assuming
there are no dependencies whatsoever and
then when you start trying to construct
a reputation you run into problems and
you say aha this this means that there
must be a dependency
you add it to yourself so so the these
things are being done in the solvers
there are many complicated ways of doing
this and I I would like to highlight
just two of these equivalences here with
all this complexity of the different
parameters that could be thrown in here
is one expansion based system which is
explained by this proof system and there
is one particular kind of cdcl style uh
solver
whose runs give rise to proofs of this
form but this is by no means an
equivalence it's just saying that this
is contained there so the equivalence
question we are still very far away from
there are many more proof systems here
are they solvers corresponding to those
as far as I know they are not
some some surprises or maybe even
distractions one could say in this
context uh
evaluating the qdf is an inherently
sequential two-player game so one would
think that any cdcl Style run in a trail
should make decisions in at least
respecting the alternation model within
a block maybe you can choose whatever
order of the variables but if you have a
universal variable depending on previous
existentials you should not decide it
before knowing these preceding values so
it seems like level order is a
completely reasonable policy for the
decision policy and the surprise is that
theoretically any order has also been
shown to be sound
another thing is that solvers don't know
a priority whether an input is true or
false so of course you treat every
assignment as a conflict and uh so so so
if if you end up with an assignment
which falsifies some Clause then that's
a from that you can learn a tube if you
end up with an assignment which
falsifies some
uh which which satisfies all the Clauses
then you know that some uh this Trail
cannot form part of a winning strategy
for the universal player so you learn a
cube so you should really be learning
Clauses and cubes on every Trail and
this is indeed what solvers do so
and it's not it's not conflict driven
Clause learning the C is a bit
overloaded it's conflict driven class
Cube learning so maybe just CDL and it
looks like well for false QBs you don't
need to learn cubes learning Clauses
would be enough for completeness but
learning cubes actually helps
similarly dependency schemes whether you
choose to use them or ruin your solver
well it it can ever lengthen approve it
if you look at a proof system dependency
schemes if at all they help they don't
harm but when you look at
qcdcl algorithmic runs uh some recent
work that we have done actually shows
that whether you use or don't use a
dependencies scheme can can make the
systems incomparable so it seems very
counterintuitive that using a dependent
system can actually slow down a solver
so some questions which arise from here
very briefly
um
can we Implement solvers based on those
more complex group systems that are
sitting on top and or are they just
proof theoretic uh constructs that are
of no relevance to practice this I do
not know
um can we actually understand uh what
are the proof systems that characterize
heuristics which are used in practice
again this we do not know dependency
learning as far as you know has not been
captured in any proof system so far
so this was a very brief uh run through
of the solving perspective and now I
still have this one thing so I'm going
to take one minute two minutes maximum I
think one minute okay the cookware
framework okay the corporate framework
says that polynomial size normally
verifiable this is NP but if you can
also do this for onp then point equals
NP so it's it's about implementing
non-determinism with P space the
situation is different because P space
NP space going to space we already know
they are equal so what happens if qbf
has policized poly verifiable probes it
means that P space is equal to NP and I
prefer to read this as NP space is equal
to NP because then what it tells us is
that such group systems the existence of
such proc systems is a question about
whether non-deterministic space can be
collapsed with time
on the other hand if you go all the way
up to any XP then provably we know that
there aren't polynomial sized polynomial
time verifiable probes that will
contradict the time hierarchy but what
we can ask for with any XPS are their
exponential size groups which are
verifiable in time which is polynomial
in the length of the proof and these
exist foreign by the definition of
non-deterministic computation but do
these kind of proofs exist for coelp if
they did exist then co-nax P would be
equal to any XP and this is again
similar to the original Cooperative
question a question about complementing
non-determinism so the reason for this
slide is to say that the question at qbf
is fundamentally different it's about
collapsing space to time not about
complementing non-determinism and
because it is fundamentally such a
different question we should be thinking
about ubf proofs in a completely
different way not in the style that has
been used there
is uh there was one slide here which I
had about dependency qbx and multi-party
games which I won't describe but I think
this is a nice message to take NP
corresponds to one player games P space
corresponds to two player games any XP
the next you know exponential length
proofs that corresponds to multi-party
games and you could use that to design
solvers for dqbs if you ask me I I find
it hard to believe that dpvx always are
for real even NP is bad enough no it's
hard enough we are thinking of these
phase proofs and then there are people
who are building there are dqvs always
which are currently being written and
maybe the questions that should be asked
there are what fragments or do you have
genuinely give you the succinctness to
empower your constraints so actually
this is one question which I think is
interesting
any XP dqvf is a complete problem but
another complete problem is Success so
each dqbf is a succinct representation
of CNF sat so if we can talk about
succinct representations of formulas we
should ask for succinct representations
of proofs and maybe that will throw up
some new ideas so these are the
questions which come from the
computational complexity perspective and
with that let me end with my last slide
all right
any quick questions
thank you this was great oh I
I was wondering if you could say a
little bit more about succinctness uh
because in recent years there have been
results for other systems uh where there
would be lower bound proven for
something that's not prepositionally
expressible
is there something like that happening
in the qbf world
where uh you could talk separately about
saying that you could technically write
down you know maybe even as CNF versus
things that you absolutely have to write
down as qbf so I mean how would you how
would you explain the result that
succinct sat is any XP complete
well this is one yeah so so there the
formula itself is being represented
succinctly but that takes you all the
way to any XP and I think your question
is about P space
uh yeah the question is about interplay
between expressibility versus hardness
of so yeah so not expressiveness but
succinctness yeah succinctness because
we're still expressing the same set of
constraints it's still propositional
yeah yeah so this is something that we
don't understand
you want to know how how the
succinctness plays into producing proofs
which are hard to uh
in producing formulas which are hard to
include
I think that's just restating the
question that we take
it
thank you Mina for a great talk just one
comment about the dqbf solvers that are
being built you mentioned people build a
program analysis tools for undesirable
problems just letting you know that you
know that doesn't stop you know stop
there yeah the engineering Enterprise
has to go and I agree
I guess the question that is being asked
there is different I mean when you're
building that solver you don't expect to
really solve all instances of B2B at any
rate you expect that the the instances
which on which you would want to use
this solver are arising from some
natural setting where there is some
obvious structure and you want to
exploit that structure so understand
that structured better
these are worst case complexity you're
talking about right oh so actually
actually the question which you had
asked me earlier because it is not just
about worst case
a little bit less so so your question
you want to ask about average case
yeah I mean in the context report which
I also said I mean any XP complete bqbf
this is the worst case complexity
and I mean you really require to craft
an example to hit that first place
complexity
so
oh I see okay okay so that this is a
comment in that sense so I mean I don't
see how proof complexity is going to
give answers uh easily can you talk
about complexity measures which are not
worst case complexity because that might
actually be very useful to
understand structural problems yeah so
hardness of random formulas for instance
if
most formulas are hard
then then in some sense it's like it's
answering this question right
I I don't know what are the other ways
in which one could choose to answer this
what I'm saying is worst case complexity
doesn't always help
and it shows that there is something out
there you know maybe but worst case
complexity is already a computational
construct I mean the proof's complexity
world I do not know what is the yeah
okay so maybe that is your question what
is the analog yeah I I do not know
all right thank you
[Applause]
it's time for lunch and we will
reconvene at 2PM right
thank you